ein halbes jahr zuvor ist das passiert
ich brauch nicht wieder arbeiten alle
üblichen 1000 euro wenn ich jetzt diesen
knopf clique dann ist weg vielen dank
ihr auftrag wurde erfolgreich
übermittelt okay jetzt wird zum ersten
mal ernst ich habe noch nicht wirklich
viel ahnung ich weiß was ich hier gerade
jetzt euro und dollar handelt weiß dass
ich hier sachen kaufen und verkaufen
kann natürlich sehr gute motive fällt
wenn mein erster trade einfach direkt in
die hose geht 13 13 cent also okay ich
habe 1000 euro eingezahlt hat das 1000
euro 13 ich könnte jetzt auflösen und da
hätte ich die 60 cent aber natürlich
nicht und jetzt gehen nach oben und
jetzt habe ich bin - ich frage mich
langsam ob es dann nicht mehr sinn
machen würde einfach in münster aachen
verlassen weil ich einfach nie richtig
liegt das sieht in dem was wir bisher
gesehen hat wahrscheinlich alles auch
das hätte ich gar kein planung will ich
einfach aus meinem bauchgefühl heraus
entscheiden und janna klar einerseits
habe ich noch immer kein plan und ich
denke auch dass eine woche dazu nicht
wirklich ausreichend land zu haben einen
ganzen monat hingegen das könnte reichen
ich werde weiteres mal 1000 euro
investieren aber mich diesmal mehr
informieren gewinn versprechende
strategien befolgen und meine emotionen
knallhart kontrollieren lernen um
herauszufinden ob ich nach vier wochen
schon mit profit dasteht
dieses video wird unterstützt von pasta
wein übrigens lust auf mehr solcher
selbst experimente astana bonn ihr gern
diesen kanal dann siehst du die videos
auch selbst wenn wir die götter nicht
gnädig gestimmt sind im vorgänger zu
diesem video habe ich bereits erklärt
was man daytrading genau macht das ist
echt ein extrem kompliziertes thema aber
im rahmen des videos können und müssen
wir das auch extrem simplifizieren grob
runtergebrochen kaufmann beim
cfd-trading keine echte aktie sondern
nur virtuelle finanzprodukte die den
kurs einer echten aktie oder währung
nachbilden erwartet man jetzt bei einer
aktie oder bei einer währung steigende
kurse kaufmann also jetzt cfds und
verkauft sie später zu dem daneben
gestiegenen preis mit einem gewinn
wieder jetzt wird es ein bisschen
knifflig erwarte man fallende kurse kann
man sich cfds auch laien und dann direkt
zum aktuellen preis verkaufen wenn der
kurs gefallen ist kauft man sich das
gleiche ding zu den günstigeren preis
wieder gibt es an den verleiher zurück
und darf natürlich den unterschied
zwischen einer anfangs teuer und am ende
günstig gehalten kurz gesagt ist es
komplett egal ob die kurse steigen oder
fallen
wir wissen da vorher bescheid und ob das
möglich ist dass vorherzusehen natürlich
nicht immer aber zumindest öfter richtig
zulegen als man fall schlägt mit den
verschiedensten mustern und strategien
dass wenn wir jetzt raus
in den ersten drei tagen mache ich noch
keinen einzigen trade sondern lerner und
lese bzw höhere bücher eine der
grundlegenden strategien ist die trend
verfolgung an kann kann sowohl nach oben
und nach unten gehen einen aufwärtstrend
zum beispiel besteht solange wie das
darauffolgende hoch über dem
vorhergehenden hoch liegt und das
folgende tief ebenso höher als das
vorherige team daran kann man dann seine
kauf oder verkaufsentscheidungen
orientieren aber ein trend kann
natürlich bestätigt werden und weiter
gehen oder es kommt zur trendwende
ein ganz spannender fall hier habe ich
quasi den trend erkannt der ja schon
eine weile hier ja das buch ist immer
höher und die tiefsten auch immer höher
deswegen bin ich zum allerersten mal vor
allem schon hier eingegangen bei dieser
linie die zeit angezeigt habe dann habe
ich mir den kanal angezeigten oder ist
dann später der kurs genau an diesem
kanal kurz abgebremst ist bin ich da
quasi dann nochmal eingestiegen mit der
zweiten position die man hier unten
sieht das jetzt zum beispiel sehr gut
funktioniert das waren zwei sehr gute
einsteiger jetzt wird aber schwierig
hier den ausstieg zu finden
zur richtigen zeit rein zu gehen ist
eine sache zur richtigen zeit zu wissen
wann es gut ist dass wir jetzt die kunst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der kanal wurde gerade durchbrochen das
muss noch nichts heißen aber ich werde
mir meinen teil der profite hier
mitnehmen und schon mal in einen der
beiden trades schließen und den anderen
würde ich verkaufen sobald der kurs noch
mal tiefer wird als dieses letzte tief
hier mal schauen
hier seht ihr einmal im block a 1 und v1
an denen ich die position gekauft und
verkauft haben und in orange für die
zweite position mit der ersten position
habe ich einen dollar und 11 cent profit
gemacht danach ging der kurs aber wie
befürchtet steil nach unten wo mich dann
mein stopp loss abgesichert hat einen
stop-loss ist eine grenze die man
angeben kann hat der wenn der kurs
darunter fällt automatisch verkauft wird
damit man eben nicht zu weit ins minus
geht wusste der übrigens dass man
verluste beim aktienhandel gegen seine
gewinne steuerlich absetzen kann aber
auch wenn nichts mit trading armut hat
verschenkt wahrscheinlich eine menge
geld zwölf millionen deutsche machen
nämlich keine steuererklärung und das
obwohl neun von zehn leute die eine
steuererklärung abgeben im schnitt mehr
als 1000 euro pro jahr vom staat
zurückbekommen jetzt fragst du dich
bestimmt also ich hab keine ahnung davon
und gar keine lust das zu machen
deswegen kann ich dir taster empfehlen
du registrierst dich einfach mit wenigen
klicks auf ciao.de und gibt ein paar
daten wie name adresse und steuer id 1
dauert keine fünf minuten ohne
papierkram ohne stress und die lassen
einen kostenlos checken ob du geld
zurückbekommen wie viel du
zurückbekommen sagt jetzt hast du dann
nach drei tagen und schickt ihr ein
angebot
ja und dann entscheidest du doch keine
lust oder sollen zwar ist das top
steuerberater seine steuererklärung
einreichen
das beste ist die gebühr wird erst
fällig wenn deine stärke da ist wie wir
nämlich am ende automatisch mit einer
erstattung verrechnet das heißt du hast
gar kein risiko
wenn du dir also was vom finanzamt
zurückholen will hall der taster den
link dazu findet ihr unten in der
infobox auch in der zweiten woche
besuche ich vorsichtig zu traden während
ich parallel mehr wissen aufbauen
ich lerne nach und nach die charts also
diese kurs diagramme besser kennen es
gibt zum beispiel linien walten und
candlestick chart ich wähle die
candlesticks und lerne du als über die
tage verschiedene formationen und
auffälligkeiten zu deuten so eine
kendall beziehungsweise kerze stellt den
verlauf des kurses für ein spezielles
zeitfenster da hier zum beispiel zehn
minuten diese box der kerze gibt an wo
der kurs links angefangen und nach zehn
minuten rechts geändert hat die dochte
der kerze nach oben und unten zeigen an
innerhalb dieser zehn minuten das
minimum und maximum war da die woche
zwar jetzt nicht so prickelnd verlief
mit bis dato vier prozent - also 40 euro
verlust habe ich meinen dritten woche
folgen das gedacht bisher habe ich ja
nur die technische chartanalyse gemacht
aber vielleicht liegt es mir besser die
nachrichten zu verfolgen und danach zu
handeln
ich lese mal vor angefangen habe ich mit
einem video der mega die bahnbrechenden
heftigen grafik heraus gebracht wovon
ich jetzt hier in genauen 8 cent
profitiert habe kann man sehen lassen
vielleicht habt ihr mitgekriegt dass die
usa ein bisschen sanktionen gegen einige
chinesische unternehmen erhebt und so
haben wir auch gesagt hey tik tok wenn
ihr in den usa wissen dass machen wollt
müsst ihr den usa teil einer us firma
verkaufen microsoft wollte hat es aber
nicht bekommen also habe ich mein
microsoft auf fallende kurse gesetzt
die sind aber trotzdem gestiegen und ich
habe acht dollar miese gemacht oracle
hatte dann mehr erfolg und die haben die
us sparte von tik tok bekommen weswegen
ich bei denen auf steigende kurse
gesetzt habe und da ein dollar 13 cent
profit gemacht haben und jetzt das beste
kurz vor thessas patchday und letzte
hauptversammlung dort wo sie
mittlerweile bahnbrechende fortschritte
in der batterietechnik angekündigt haben
ja kurz davor gab es spekulationen die
aus mehreren tweets hervorgehen dass
tesla eine kooperation mit dem weltweit
größten nickel produktionsfirma eingehen
könnte und das kann ich jetzt auch nicht
wirklich entschuldigen weil das war
nämlich wirklich dumm und das sieht dann
im ganzen grafik so aus
[Musik]
woche vier von vier bericht an das
experiment nähert sich dem ende zu
aktuell bin ich ja minimal im minus aber
ich habe viele aus meinen fehlern
gelernt bin konzentrierter ruhiger und
strenger denn je
theoretisch sollte ich das wurde ja also
in der letzten woche locker rumreißen
können
das toplos für die letzte position ist
kurz hielt runter kann natürlich sein
dass der trend jetzt bestehen bleibt und
es wieder hochgeht kann natürlich auch
sein dass es jetzt hier komplett in bach
runtergeht ich hatte eigentlich meinst
du das tier gesetzt weil hier der halt
unter ist vorher aktiv jetzt gegangen
ist meinte jetzt halt nochmal unter das
tief geht dann greift das doppel
auseinander sonst vielleicht genau hier
ist das neue tief gerade quasi unter das
vorherige tief begangen da ist natürlich
jetzt ein guter zeitpunkt um rauszugehen
da hat auch das doppel aus gegriffen und
jetzt quasi mit den drei trades circa 18
dollar profit gemacht ist aber trotzdem
noch ein weiter weg bis wir wieder ins
profitable gehen gerade da sind wir
nämlich noch bei 200 -
donald trump hat gerade getwittert dass
er ohne hut ich gehe davon aus und das
hat sich auch schon gezeigt dass
deswegen der dollar im verhältnis zum
euro fallen wird bzw der euro dadurch
absteigen wird ich glaube nicht dass das
eine katastrophe wird aber ich denke
schon dass es eine kurzfristige chance
ist zu dumpf klingt auch wenn ich selbst
donald trump gute besserung wünschen
aber ist trotzdem makabre weise jetzt
eine chance hiervon zu profitieren
der monat ist vorbei wir ziehen bilanz
als dem monat gereicht um die theorie
und das emotions management in griff zu
kriegen oder muss nach einer woche und
einem monat jetzt auch noch ein ganzes
jahr cfd-trading kommen verdienen habe
ich also interessant gar nix ich hab
sogar verlust gemacht obwohl ich in der
letzten und vierten woche erst einmal 20
euro prophet also 0,2 prozent profit
gemacht habe hat das natürlich nicht
ausgereicht um die heftigen fehler von
davor mir auszubügeln aber gut ich
wusste dass das risiko sehr hoch ist
gerade für den anfänger da richtig viel
geld zu verlieren ein realistisches ziel
kann natürlich auch nicht sein aus 1000
euro jetzt innerhalb von ein paar wochen
ihren millionen zu zaubern derweil um so
was du kriegen müsste man schon wirklich
hardcore risikoreich sein könnte dann
natürlich auch heftig schuld machen klar
aber auch das ziel minimal langsamen
profit zu machen habe ich auch nicht
hinkriegt lag dachte jetzt daran dass es
ganz nah und glücksspiel ist wo die
meisten leute die nur draufzahlen
oder daran dass ich einfach immer noch
nach einem monat viel zu wenig erfahrung
ruhe und skater na ja so ein bisschen
bald natürlich also einerseits ist und
wirklich riskant und keiner kann die
zukunft vorhersehen aber ich könnte mir
schon auch nach den negativen
erfahrungen immer noch vorstellen dass
jemand der das selbst jahrelang macht
mit einer kleinen summen damit der nie
wird viel geld verliert mit den
richtigen risikomanagement und alles
drum und dran auf lange zeit schon
profit machen kann ich persönlich bleibe
da werde ich mal lieber beim
langfristigen investieren wie ich es
auch schon mal in einem älteren video
von mir besprochen habe wo ich über
meine finanzen geredet habe stichwort
etf und vielleicht auch ein paar
einzelne aktien von firmen an die ich
glaube das hat bei mir privat zumindest
bisher in der kurzen zeit auch
tatsächlich relativ erfolgreiche klappt
im vergleich zu dem wohl die theoretisch
ein bisschen was lernen müsste oder
vielleicht mehr als ein bisschen ich
mache fast jede woche eines dieser
experimente wenn er schon wissen möchte
was das nächste ist schaut gerne auf
instagram vorbei da findet ihr häufig
schon hinweise der link zu taster ist in
dem video beschreibung und wenn ich
jetzt auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
abonniert gerne diesen kanal und dann
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]